so you said this is the guy that
initially set you up yeah eventually he
was the one
um how how far into this [ __ ] did you
get before he set you up like how long
did you were you working with him uh
with I was doing the counterfeiting
thing for about two years I think he
came in the picture probably the last
I want to say six eight months like we
had a good uh
you know so like like I said the Bible
paper thing
um
it was hard to come by so after going to
bookstores and all this so I basically I
was went to a hotel one day and went in
the the end table to get the Bible to
you know get a couple pieces of paper
out of it or whatever
um and that wasn't there
so I waved down the maintenance man and
I was like hey there's not a Bible in my
room can you get me a Bible so he was
like yeah I'll get you one I'll be right
back I was like you know what you guys
not keep Bibles in the nightstand
anymore and he's like no we stopped
doing that I got boxes full of Bibles in
the maintenance closet so I was like you
know like give me those by I'll pay you
for those boxes you know what I mean I
got a lot of praying to do today and
that that particular guy actually like I
I think I gave him like 100 bucks for
all these boxes Bibles or something
um and so I got him in the room that's
probably like five boxes I went through
took all the blank pages and then just
went through the boxes in the dumpster
you know so he noticed that and he was
like I remember he was like asking me
like why the [ __ ] did you just pay me
for these Bibles and then throw them
away you know it didn't make sense to
him but but yeah so we started uh
basically paying maintenance men at
different hotels to to you know bring me
boxes of Bibles which that definitely
increased the the production you know so
this guy was going up to Cleveland how
many bills could you fit into one Bible
page uh like your your typical Bible
about like this that you'd find in a
hotel room or something it's just one
side per page so like because I'm
printing the front and the back so like
those you know at a there's usually like
about four pages in those little Bibles
so I mean it's worth 200 bucks so it's
not that you need to get lots of them
but there there's other specific types
of of Bibles like for instance the
Jeremiah Study Bible specifically it's
it's a study Bible so the back was full
of blank pages to take notes on it said
like notes at the top and it was just
like 30 blank pages and the Bible was
probably you know this big notes so
print notes all right
so you could fit probably three sides
like a front a back and another front on
one page and you know there was say 40
blank pages
so you know what's what is that 40 times
uh times three
120 I mean the one Bible's worth about
10 grand okay you know what I mean so
like if you go into a Barnes Noble for
instance there's probably two or three
copies of the Jeremiah Study Bible and
get those and then
you know random other ones I mean like I
said a bookstore you could probably get
about say 50 at least 50 000 worth of
paper from One Bookstore but most cities
only have like two bookstores in the
city right you know what I mean so if
you go to Chattanooga
but you hit the two bookstores there you
know that's fifty fifty a hundred
thousand dollars out of Chattanooga you
know you go to Atlanta there's say three
bookstores there there's 150 out of
Atlanta but it comes to a point to where
I went to Atlanta Chattanooga Knoxville
you know Sevierville uh
Lexington
Cleveland you know you just because when
you're busting these bills you also want
to travel around you know I mean I think
I think the number that I spent in
Knoxville was like three hundred and
eighty thousand dollars uh throughout
businesses in Knoxville which that I got
a little ballsy you spent 380
000 not just on Bibles but like spending
the money no just yeah shopping
to convert that money into you know real
money you'd go shopping you'd buy
something for 10 20 bucks what kind of
[ __ ] were you buying
oh just random [ __ ] I got the time you
know I had a heroin habit so yeah it was
converted to cash and then you know I'd
buy Visa cards to pay for the hotel
rooms and you know had some designer
bags jewelry [ __ ] like that I mean
nothing was no like Ferraris but I mean
you know just living living comfortably
right right wow so how did this guy
eventually set you up
um
so one day he told me he was like oh I
bought this uh it was a I think a 2009
Charger or something I guess one of
these dudes that uh
was bindo from him was like oh he sold
him a car for like I think it was 500 in
an eight ball of heroin
for a 2009 Charger so I was like bro
that's a stolen car 100 he's like no the
guy gave me a title he's like it's all
good I'm gonna go register it I was like
bro you bought that from a junkie for
500 bro it's a [ __ ] stolen car I
promise you either way he was convinced
because he he had the title the guy has
a title so to him so I was supposed to
uh go up to Cleveland with him
um to you know we had maintenance guy
that was going to give us some Bibles up
there uh I was going to you know bust
bills throughout the city while he
re-upped on some dope
um but like the day before we were
supposed to leave I ended up getting
arrested for a failure to appear like a
little little Warren I had
um so I got arrested the next day bond
out but he already went without me I
guess so uh
we were renting a house together and I
was kind of you know printing the money
out of the back and he was selling
selling dope out of the front and we
shared this house so I bond out of jail
on that little charge and I go home and
his little Runner chick a summer uh
she basically said like oh he went up to
Cleveland without you
so I was like okay whatever you know
what I mean and then
she basically said like don't uh you
know he told me not to tell you this but
he got arrested up in Cleveland
so
instantly I was like you know why would
he why would he tell you not to tell me
like that's sketchy you know it's a red
flag for sure
[Music]
um
and I knew at first I I figured it was
probably that car I'm like I knew that
car was stolen you know I mean but I
also knew he was going up there with he
had 20 000 in real cash and five
thousand in my bills at the time
so I knew
you know whether it was because of the
car or not he most likely got caught
with you know counterfeit money or
heroin one of the two you know and uh
you know by him telling her not to tell
me that he got arrested is in my mind
he's cooperating you know I'm trying to
he's going to set me up or attempt to at
some point so
um I got you know my computers and
printers and I had ventilation fans just
to spray the lacquer indoors it would
suck it out the window like a whole like
Productions counterfeiting a little
setup you know what I mean but when I
found out he was locked up I got
everything and went to a hotel I was
like [ __ ] this I'm leaving
um which I'm well I mean I'm glad I did
but ultimately I got arrested anyway but
um
so I'm staying in a hotel
um
and this other group of Detroit guys put
in like an order for like six thousand
dollars so I was my plan was to to wake
up make this six thousand to give these
Detroit guys my you know my wife at the
time is gonna go shopping whatever it
was just like a normal day every day
um and this dude e the guy from
Cleveland calls me
so he basically was like hey I've got
these that book a box of Bibles for you
and I was like well just hold on to him
I don't want to meet up right now you
know I mean like I assume he's
cooperating
um and he basically said I was like
eventually basically I was
like wow you know you just got arrested
why didn't you tell me that you know I
mean like what you tell summer not to
tell me bro you're acting you're acting
[ __ ] sketchy
um and you know he had this story which
kind of made sense but I still didn't
trust him you know he basically said
yeah that car was stolen
I got arrested for it the money I was
gonna use to buy the dope I had to bond
out with so I couldn't re-up in
Cleveland so now I'm back in Knoxville
and I need to re-up can you get me like
a 700 grams from your Detroit people
which is like I don't sell you know I
didn't really sell a lot of drugs like
that you know what I mean so for him to
ask me that
over the phone after he just got out of
jail like it was a huge red flag and
he's trying he's trying to set me up for
things that I don't even do you know
what I mean like I'm doing the
counterfeiting thing it um so
basically like he asked me that and I
was like listen bro like we're not
having this conversation especially not
over the phone you know what are you
talking about you're the drug dealer I'm
Not Goodbye so I hang up
um I guess the
they GPS pinged my phone though to my
location
so they knew they didn't know which room
I was in but they knew that I was in the
extended stay hotel in West Knoxville so
you know like I said that next morning
my wife's gonna go shopping I was gonna
you know print six thousand for this guy
so they leave
and I didn't know this at the time but I
guess as soon as my wife got in the car
and started to pull out they swarmed her
you know I mean the police it was the
Knox uh KPD organized crime unit drug
task force Cleveland Secret Service
Knoxville Secret Service
you know multiple different agencies uh
so basically I but I didn't know this my
wife just left to go shopping you know
so I'm in there hanging paper spraying
it cutting printing all this stuff and I
I hear a knock on the door and I you
know look through the peephole uh and
it's just black like somebody's thumb
was over the people
so at first I was thinking like oh this
is like maybe somebody's trying to rob
me or something I didn't know because
but I look out the window and I saw a
line at Knox County Sheriffs you know
what I mean so oh [ __ ] yeah I go to to
flush some of the the money that I was
printing I threw a bunch in the toilet
and flushed it you know went down threw
a bunch more and went to flush it and
they shut the water off because they
thought I had a bunch of kilos of drugs
in there and stuff oh okay so there was
a bunch of
one-sided like unfinished counterfeit
money all in toilet and [ __ ]
it did the first time but the second
time I guess
no good but I mean at that point I I was
already in there with you know I'm in a
hotel room there's nowhere to go what
kind of [ __ ] did you have in that you
had printers in there printers computers
uh
you know all the different sprays my
little glass light board to like cut
everything on and line everything up
with and the worst part was the the
files on the computer you know all those
serial numbers I changed every serial
number so when I got the computer as
evidence that basically linked me to all
these different serial numbers that they
found throughout the country
foreign